[Musique]
pourquoi on n pas capable d'exiger le
même degré de sécurité financière qu'on
exige de sécurité nucléire alors que les
risques sont quand même même de
[Musique]
grandeur bonjour messieurs nous avons
décid
à cette réunion pour parler des
États-Unis et plus particulièrement de
l'économie
américaine nous avons un notre table
Hervé de Carnois qui va prendre la
parole Hervé qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire sur les principaux indicateurs
économiques américains leur véracité
leur leur ténacité est-ce qu'ils font
réellement passer une information
correcte pas correcte qu'est-ce que vous
en
pensez l'économie américaine est en
croissance légère à des
renouvelle en
partie
son sa puissance intérieure à
travers un niveau
d'inventivité tout à fait
[Musique]
important et c'est un marché de 310
millions de personnes avec trois pôles
de puissance hein premier pôle de
puissance c'est l'armée le deuxème pôle
de puissance c'est la finance le trè p
de puissance et la technologie et ils
sont intimement liés
donc est-ce que l'économie américaine va
continuer à une faible croissance je
dirais que c'est probable et que leur
principal handicap est la finance
phipéch qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire sur cette croissance américaine
Estelle Scine sur qu sur quelle base
cette croissance se
fonde depuis 2009 il est clair que les
injections massives et successives de la
Fed ont certainement contribué à une
forme de relance mais un petit peu
indirect puisque c'est au travers en
fait des dépenses de l'État que
l'impression monétaire a rendu possible
donc on va dire que c'est pas une
croissance
autonome depuis 2010 il y a une très
nette montée en puissance euh de la
production
d'énergie non conventionnelle ce qu'on
appelle les fameux gaz de
schiste qui assure une relative
indépendance ou en tout cas permettre
aux États-Unis de faire quand même de
grosses
économies en terme de d'échange
extérieur donc pas de gaspillage de
ressources donc on dire que là c'est de
la croissance par économie
induite pour le reste et bien
effectivement
entre finance
lobby de l'armement puis j'ajouterai
quand même la puissante machine
hollywoodienne puisque les
droits audio ça représente quand même
quelque chose de non négligeable aux
États-Unis donc on a
effectivement on va dire
trois piliers et demi pour soutenir une
croissance je veux le préciser je pense
qu'Olivier en dira certainement un mot
une croissance qui n'est pas du tout
créatrice d'emploi Olivier de la marche
aujourd'hui on est euh on est dans un
système où euh il faut à peu près euh 6
dollars de dett pour faire un dollar de
PIB en gros donc euh j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit un système qui
soit soutenable à moyen terme et à long
terme
euh vous êtes sur quelque chose qui est
euh
euh qui est uniquement euh je dirais
étatique c'est-à-dire que on a eu entre
98 et 2008 on a eu les ménages
américains qui se sont endettés de 1000
milliards de dollars par an bon 2008 fin
du jeu ils arrêtent parce qu'ils sont
surendettés et qu'on commence à les
virer de leur maison de leur voitures et
compagnie donc
euh fin du jeu qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
bah vous avez l'État qui a pris le
relais de ça et qui s'est copieusement
endetté en l'espace de 4 ans 5 ans donc
euh à raison à peu près d'ailleurs de de
de 1000 milliards dollars par par an
donc vous êtes sur quelque chose qui
chaque chaque dollar de PIB et est fait
par de la dette d'État donc je pense que
ça n'ira pas très très loin comme ça
Olivier beruer je voudrais votre
position sur la nouvelle position de
Jeanette Kellen sur le Quantitative
Easing qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire dessus euh bon on a bien compris
qu'évidemment le quantitétive easing va
se poursuivre les États-Unis sont de
toute façon via la fê dans quasi
impossibilité d'arrêter le
quantittativeing on c'est bien dès
qu'ils vont débrancher vous allez avoir
des sousbressau énormes au niveau de la
Bourse c'est des conséquences majeures
sur les sur les entreprises
financières pour en revenir sur la
partie PIB bon comme l'a dit Olivier ces
trois dernières années c'est 500
milliards de croissance c'est 3000
milliards de dettes donc un rendement
pour le moins pas très intéressant
deuxème axe ça c'est pe souligné issu
des travaux d'Emmanuel 16 qui regarde
d'assz près ce qui se passe sur les sur
les inégalités aux ÉtatsUnis Unis qui
dit croissance supplémentaire ces
dernières années dit en contrepartie
augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
augmentation des salaires c'est c'est la
contrepartie de C de cette croissance il
a regardé quelle était la fraction de
l'augmentation depuis 3 ans tout ce a
été créé de nouveau qui a été capté par
le 1 % le plus riche aux États-Unis et
il est arrivé à ce chiffre assez amusant
de 120 %. autrement dit le 1 % le plus
riche a capté toute la richesse qui a
été créée et en plus a continué à piquer
sur la richesse et les les revenus la
part de revenu des 99 % les plus pauvres
ce qui veut simplement dire que les
États-Unis c'est 99 % de la population
qui est toujours en récession depuis
2009 et 1 % où ça va beaucoup mieux
effectivement quand on fait la moyenne
de tout ça vu de loin on dire bah oui ça
croit un petit peu mais c'est comme si
en terme d'image on disait qu'il y a une
croissance fabuleuse à Washington et
tout le reste du pays est en récession
et en moyenne oui en moyenne c'est quand
même positif parce que le poids capté
par le 1 % est est phénoménal aux
États-Unis
c'est
indiscutable comment les Américains ont
la
capacité de voir les écarts de fortune
se multiplier par des multiples
considérables euh il l'acceptte hein il
l'acceptte et que font ces Américains
est-ce qu'ils investissent à l'étranger
non très peu
hein est-ce qu'ils font des dons
beaucoup ils se sont multipliés par 6
depuis 10 10 an est-ce qu'ils
investissent dans leur propre pays avec
précaution hein ils ils font des
investissements est-ce qu'ils sont
concernés par la création d'emploi très
peu est-ce qu'ils veulent aller
vers les brevets nouveaux et les
inventions nouvelles généralement donc
et enfin si vous voulez bien investir il
faut un investisseur et il faut une
banque hein il faut autre chose bien sûr
or le système bancaire reste
fragile peu
entrepreneurial
et donc l'image qu'on qui ressort de
tout ça est une image mitigé
Hervé je rebondis encore est-ce que vous
pouvez nous parler des chiffres du
chômage américain comment comment
sont-il calculés qu quel quelle est la
véracité de ces chiffres quand on
regarde le le le bureau fbor sur la
méthode faite on se rend compte qu'il y
a pratiquement 1 million de chôeurs qui
sont sortis des liste ça ninfluence sur
le dernier trimestre sur le dernier
trimestre merci Hervé Hervé qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire
dessus que que les Américains euh comme
toujours gèent l'image avant le contenu
dans tous les domaines hein je veux dire
c'est une tendance des 50 derniers
dernires années bon donc il présente une
image aussi positive que possible de
leur chômage qui est autour de 7,6 %
hein qui était il y a 10 ans autour de 4
et5i 5 % donc qui s'est
détérioré les Américains se trouvent
devant un dilemme qu'il n'arrivent pas à
résoudre et ce dilemme est comment
augmentons-nous la richesse qui se crée
et emploi or à l'heure actuelle dans
l'industrie et dans les services de la
richesse secrée elle n'est pas
génératrice
d'emploi monsieur de la marche est-ce
que vous pouvez nous déléger un petit
peu plus les chiffres du chômage et
ensuite monsieur béchad est-ce que vous
pouvez nous parler des municipal bonds
et de la dette étudiante Olivier j'ai
une mauvaise nouvelle pour Monsieur
Bernand c'est pas en rachetant des
obligation vous faites baisser le
chômage alors il l'a cru pendant un
moment ou il a fait semblant d'y croire
plutôt
mais à part le trader que vous allez
engager pour appuyer sur le bouton je
vois pas qui peut être engagé de plus
pour faire baisser le chômage on est on
a des chiffres du chômage
américain on a toutes les statistiques
c'est l'avantage des États-Unis vous ne
les avez pas en Europe par exemple où on
vous donne aussi un chiffre qui est loin
de la réalité sauf que vous n'avez pas
les moyens de le vérifier aux États-Unis
vous avez les moyens de le vérifier et
c'est assez assez facile les
statistiques sont assez bien faites donc
aujourd'hui si on recalcule les choses
avec le taux moyen du taux de
participation à la population active de
de de aux États-Unis vous retomber sur
des chiffres qui sont au sens large hein
donc la la composante qu' appellent U6
au sens large c'est-à-dire les gens qui
sont complètement sortis les gens qui
sont indemnisés plus et cetera vous êtes
autour de entre 18 et 19 % de chômage
aux États-Unis ça fait un Américain sur
5 alors évidemment ça d'ailleurs vous
pouvez corroborer chiffre par le nombre
d'Américains qui sont au foot stamp hein
vous en avez à peu près un petit peu
moins de 50 millions donc c'est-à-dire
un petit peu moins de 15 % autour autour
de 15 % de la population
euh donc vous êtes sur une sur un un un
un pays qui par définition ne peut
pas créer de la de la valeur créer du
PIB autrement que par la dette et
autrement que par la dette d'État
donc je dirais maintenant c'est c'est il
y a il y a vraiment plus de question à
seoser vous avez des entreprises qui
continuent à virer du monde il y a des
annonces à peu près tous les jours
pourquoi bah parce que elles essaie de
conserver des marges alors qu'elles ont
des chiffres d'affaires qui baissent
donc ça s'arrêtera à un moment ça on le
sait hein puisque une fois que vous avez
une fois qu'il reste dans le
l'entreprise le président et l'Ô Tesse
d'accueil ça fait un peu ça fait un peu
court
donc ça s'arrêtera à un moment mais ça
s'arrêtera avec avec un taux élevé et
qui ne baissera pas qui ne baissera pas
en tout cas on ne retrouvera jamais les
taux d'avant c'est-à-dire le taux de
plein emploi qui était autour de 4 % aux
États-Unis vous ne le retrouverez pas
Philippe les municipal bonds la dette
étudiante alors je vais commencer
effectivement peut-être par la dette
étudiante qui permet de rebondir sur ce
queivier vient de dire donc on a un
marché du travail qui ne se fluidie pas
qui ne se fluidifie pas aux États-Unis
naturellement puisque les entreprises
sont réticentes à
embaucher dans la mesure où elles savent
bien que les
débouchés naturel en tout cas le
consommateur aux États-Unis il est pour
l'instant presque
presque verrouillé séquestré
séquestré donc un marché de l'emploi qui
ne s'ouvre pas qui ne s'ouvre pas aux
jeunes évidemment ça rend les choses
compliqué qu'est-ce que font les jeunes
aujourd'hui ils allongent la durée des
études maintenant on va dire que la
norme c'est devenu le master alors que
quand on était au niveau Licence ou
maîtrise on trouvait facilement de
l'emploi on pouvait encore approfondir
mais fallait avoir les moyens est-ce que
ça représente un risque pour les banques
que ce marché des futurs étudiants ne
trouvent pas de travail et ne puisse pas
rembourser ça représente à peu près quel
volume de dette la dette étudiante c'est
1300 milliards à ma connaissance mais
alors voilà les banques ne risquent là
strictement rien puisque la
particularité des présétudiants c'est
qu'ils sont en fait garantis par l'État
mais il a bien Fall qu'un jour ou
l'autre quelqu'un paye l'ardoise or ce
qu'on appelle le taux de délinquence de
défaut potenti
sur les prèétudiants aujourd'hui il est
officiellement de 12.5 il est en réalité
de 20 % ou 20 ou 25 donc 25 % 2300
Milliards bon on va calculer grosso modo
ça fera de 250 milliards la charge de
l'État il faudra trouver ces 250
milliardes il n'existe pas donc planche
habillet naturellement en ce qui
concerne les munibonds alors là on a
assisté tout récemment c'était
mi-novembre à une ou deux journées un
petit peu particulières pendant que
madame Yelen passait son audition devant
le Sénat américain et bien pendant ce
temps-là les banques j'imagine les
grands investisseurs les familles office
liquidit massivement les obligations
municipales si massivement que c'était
presque historique Onon avait pas vu de
Tell vagues de liquidation depuis
l'automne 2008 qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire c'est que après
Detroit Cleveland acron et tant
d'autres municipalités et cté du Nord
Est industriel des États-Unis on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a aussi plein de
municipalités en faillite également en
Californie qu' en a aussi en Caroline du
Sud qui y en a à peu près partout et que
là aussi on voit que la situation ne
s'améliore pas et pour des raison qu'on
a déjà évoqué c'est-à-dire que comme on
a 18 à 19 % d'Américains sans emploi les
municipalités font quand même leur
possible évidemment pour apporter un
certain
soutien donc ça ça coûte et la deuxème
chose c'est que les taxes ne rentrent
pas puisque des gens qui ont été virés
de leur maison ou de leur voiture comme
cela a été dit euh ces gens-là sont pas
non plus en moyen de payer ni les taxes
locales ni les impôts locaux
euh le la base taxable la base des gens
taxables se réduisant ceux qui restent
sont pressurés de façon beaucoup plus
importante voire insupportable donc
ceuxa finissent par quitter la ville et
aller ailleurs donc on a là une espèce
de spirale dont je ne vois vraiment pas
comment comment on peut sortir en
revanche si les municipalités font
faillite évidemment l'État renfloura
avec quoi avec de l'argent fraîchement
imprimé Olivier euh ouais moi j'aimerais
réagir sur sur la partie emploi c'est
vraiment intéressant ce qui se passe
là-bas au aux États-Unis
euh quand on regarde de façon indbutable
le nombre de chômeurs a baissé il y a
moins de chômeurs aux États-Unis après
c'est quoi un chômeur un chômeur c'est
quelqu'un qui évidemment ne travaille
pas et déclare vouloir travailler et ça
cette population là a baissé par contre
ce qui a explosé c'est le nombre de
personnes qui sont sorties de la
population active
population active c'est les gens qui
disent moi bah où je travaille où
j'aimerais travailler euh et c'est le le
chiffre que que vous citiez tout à
l'heure où on s'aperçut que le mois
dernier 1 million de personnes sont
sorties de la population active et quand
on regarde c'est des gens qui disent moi
je laisse tomber quoi je ne trouverai
pas de travail parce que je suis une
employable parce que il y a rien à
proximité parce que ça fait 2 ans que je
cherche donc voà je je je je je laisse
tomber et quand on regarde sur ce
million là les statistiques sont
vraiment très bien faites aux États-Unis
c'est vrai on a vraiment passé en France
euh bon c'est un peu laborieux mais
quand on regarde on s'aperçoit que c'est
à peu près pour moitié des gens qui
avaient plus de 65 ans parce a une
particularité aux États-Unis c'est aussi
beaucoup de gens âgés travaillent vous
avez 10 15 % des plus de 70 ans qui
travaillent moitié des vieux mais moitié
aussi des gens qui sont de en âge 30 55
ans et à l'intérieur autant d'hommees
que de femmes on a pu penser queut des
femmes qui ét bossé il y a quand même
beaucoup aussi près de 300000 américains
hommes en âge vraiment médian ont quitté
la population active donc évidemment
cela fosse complètement la notion de
taux de chaumage puisque là aussi il
faut savoir que le taux de chômage c'est
le nombre de chômeurs à rapportter à la
population active et non pas la
population totale je je vais poser une
question un peu
subversive cette lecture est faussé
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
intoxication pour maintenir un vernis
pour les investisseurs ou pour maintenir
un ver ça oui peut-être un peu mais mais
ENF tout simplement c'est aussi la
réalité les gens laissent tomber et
votre indicateur que vous regardez le
chômage n'est pas impacté par le fait
que les gens quittent la population
active le bon indicateur pour voir ce
qui se passe sur l'emploi aux États-Unis
est donné de la même façon par le par le
le bureau des statistiques américaines
vous regardez le ratio soit de
population en emploi sur la population
totale et là vous avez une chute
dramatique et constante depuis depuis
2009 sans la moindre reprise où vous
regardez le taux de participation donc
autr dit quel est le pourcentage
d'Américains qui veulent rentrer dans la
population active et là aussi il y a une
chute très importante qui n'est
absolument pas lié à des problématiques
démographiques comme on parfois on dit
ça V pas du tout vous avez ça sur chaque
tranche d'âge donc c'est vraiment la
capacité de créer des emplois aux
États-Unis qui qui qui s'affaiblit
terriblement
Hervé oui tout ce que vous dites est
exact et puis il y a le renouveau
intérieur des États-Unis hein le
renouveau intérieur des États-Unis c'est
bal
ba2l c'est-à-dire une série de milliers
d'initiatives pour redévelopper les
activités localement il y avait
8000 marché fermiers aujourd'hui il y en
avait 4000 il y a 10 ans en d'autres
termes les Américains se remettent à
faire de
l'alimentation des services de
l'éducation localement pourquoi parce
qu'ils ont vu de nombreuses études qui
ont été publiées qui disent que quand
euh starnut vient par exemple ouvrir un
magasin de grande distribution dans une
localité 13 % des dépenses restent
locales tandis que quand des euh locaux
décident de créer quelque chose 52 % de
l'argent reste localement donc ce
mouvement est en train de se développer
massivement et il n'est pas visible pour
dans les grands journaux et ailleurs
mais il y a aussi sur ce mouvement bal
ba del des indications intéressantes et
comme on voit les États-Unis c'est une
chose et son contraire ils déclinent
dans certains domaines ils se
ressaisissent dans
d'autres il y a un truc intéressant
aussi c'est toujours dans le même même
source le le les statistiques du du
travail
américain vous vous regardez le le côté
création d'emploi et là aussi il y a un
petit c'est-à-dire qu'on vous annonce un
grandenfort de publicité qui a eu 200000
créations d'emplois la dernière fois et
que c'est fabuleux ça prouve que
l'emploi red démarre alors première
chose il y a pas de création d'emploi ou
très peu dans ce qu'on appelle tous la
réindustrie isation de l'Amérique il y a
pas un emploi manufacturier qui a été
créé et que vous regardez que la
majorité sur ces sur ces 200000 emplois
créés soi-disant créé vous avez une
grande partie c'est dans le loisir c'est
moi ce que j'ai appelé un jour sur BFM
les barman et les serveurs c'est-à-dire
que vous avez une grande majorité qui
sont rémunér voilà et très peu rémunéré
c'est-à-dire c'est des c'est en général
des gens qui touchent moins de 20000ll
par par par an donc avec moins de 20000
dollars par an vous faites pas
grand-chose hein donc vous êtes presque
chômeur on va dire donc euh et c'est et
et et vous regardez après par tranche
d'âge depuis 2008 ce qui est assez
amusant c'est que c'est pas du tout la
tranche d'âge
2055 dans lequel vous avez eu le la
reprise de du travail mais c'est des
gens qui sont au-dessus 55 ans qui ont
été engagés donc au-dessus de 55 ans
avec un boulot de serveur vous allez
quand même pas très loin et il faut pas
compter là-dessus pour que il y ait une
réelle reprise du PIB américain donc euh
je veux bien qu'il y ait des initiatives
à droite et à gauche pour euh faire des
des marchés locaux et cetera mais
résiste à la crise en en pour l'instant
c'est on essaie de se raccrocher à ce
qu'on peut en plus philiip j'aurais une
question sur la dette américaine qui
l'achète qui la détient quelle
proportion selon les pays qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire
dessus j'ai pas d'ffiche avec les
chiffres précis mais enfin bon de
mémoire on va dire que le premier
créancier des États-Unis ah benah ça
c'est les États-Unis tiens alors le
deuxè bien sûr c'est la Chine avec 2200
ou 2300 Milliards le Japon avec 2000
milliards grosso
modo ensuite on trouve les monarchies
pétrolière donc là on do être autour
deell achètent toujours les monarchies
pétrolières oui par la force des choses
puisque continue d'engranger du pétrro
dollar malgré tout même si les
États-Unis commencent à liquidifier le
gaz massivement ils en ils en ortent
encore on a le Royaume-Uni qui je pense
doit détenir quelque chose comme ça 50
milliards et puis après ça on a un grand
pays européen qui est aussi farci de
tibronze c'est le Luxembourg voilà donc
mais ça s'explique parce que le
Luxembourg a quand même une vocation de
de gérant de fortune donc beaucoup de
Family Office outre leur présence à
Singapour à la City dans les Bermudes à
Dubaï on souvent aussi un petit quelque
chose en Europe pour être dans la zone
euro et donc donc le Luxembourg se
retrouve un gros détenteur mais
bon ce qu'il faut voir c'est la
dynamique de la détention or il y a pour
l'instant un détenteur qui qui progresse
à une vitesse vertigineuse c'est
naturellement donc les États-Unis
eux-mêmes avec une Fed qui rachète 77
% des emprunts de maturité 10 et je
pense que c'est 100 % pour les maturités
30 voilà donc
Olivier je voudrais avoir votre point de
vue sur auamaker et sur
kestone
HERV aubamaker
illustre que les États-Unis ont un
président peu enclin à aller dans le
plus fin détail de la mise en œuvre il a
une stratégie et Napoléon disait que la
stratégie est tout un art de mise en
œuvre donc on va dire que le président
n'est peut-être pas le plus grand strat
parce qu'il a pas choisi les hommes ou
les femmes et dans le cas de auamaker
c'est une femme qui est capable dans le
plus fin détail juridique fiscal
organisation communication de mettre en
œuvre un programme extrêmement ambitieux
donc l'écart entre le montant des
dépenses qu'il voulait faire encourir et
la réalisation et sans précédent aux
États-Unis à ma connaissance et l'échec
informatique de la mise en place est
quand même assez lamentable au pays de
Google et Microsoft voilà bien sûr
kstone comment kstone le pipeline pour
faire descendre des
hydrocarbures qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
très c'est c'est bien sûr que les les
États-Unis font ça là la réalité c'est
que les
États-Unis ayant maintenant en gros
couvert leurs besoins pétroliers se
mettent pour quelle est la stratégie de
des États-Unis ça reste une stratégie de
pouvoir mondial on peut dire que ils
l'ont moins ils l'ont plus mais la
réalité est là et donc ils font ce qu'on
fait les Anglais à la fin du 19e et au
début du 20e c'est que comme ils non
plus la puissance industrielle qu'ils
ont eu qu'ils ont encore les matières
premières qu'ils ont t encore les
matières premières agricoles ils se
placent dans pour rester au centre de la
mondialité ils se place très bien dans
tout ce qui est distribution et collecte
voilà oui on peut parler en effet de de
ce feu de paille au niveau de l'énergie
aux États-Unis où actuellement et puis
est-ce que vous faites référence au
document du New York Times c'estes 400
pages de mail exfiltré par le New York
Times où les les les profes industriels
font remonter des alertes en disant
méfiez-vous le gazchist peut être une
bulle le gaz dechiste a un fort taux de
décroissance au bout de la 3e et 4e
année euh oui c'est ça c'est qu'il faut
percer à des nouveaux puits tous les 2 3
ans donc déjà le le stock total bon il
est loin d'être négligeable on voit que
ça fait repartir un peu la la production
aux États-Unis mais enfin voà vous êtes
sur quelque chose qui a un horizon de 4
5 6 ans en terme de réserve et ce dont
on parle peu c'est que ce ce boom a une
conséquence c'est que ça a fait chuter
le prix le prix du gaz on dit c'est
génial États-Unis il ont le gaz pas cher
juste un petit problème c'est que
maintenant les pétroliers vendent à
perte et en énorme perte donc autrement
dit il ne fort plus de puit pour faire
remonter les cours donc d'ici
normalement fin 2013 début 2014 vous
allez avoir un effondrement de la de la
production qui va faire remonter
fortement le prix à des niveaux de
rentabilité donc il y voir des SOP and
Go qui vont durer qui vont durer sur
toute la sur toute la période vu la
particularité du gaz de schist dernier
point c'est qu'ils ont évidemment
commencé à percer là où c'est plus
facile donc plus le temps passe donc
2015 2016 2017 falloir aller chercher
les les zones qui sont beaucoup moins
rentables beaucoup plus cher à produire
voilà donc c'est mais c'est intéressant
enfin il y a une espèce de de de petit
nuag de fumée sur presque bientôt c'est
l'Arabie Saoudite et puis et puis en
2030 ils vont fir la planète entière ce
qui est tout à fait faux vu des simples
capacités géologiques de des États-Unis
monsieur de la marche pouz rebondir
dessus bulle bulle comme d'habitude avec
comme le disait Olivier euh un prix qui
était en 2008 de 12 dollars on sait que
ils ont
8 dollars de coût
d'extraction aujourd'hui ça vaut 3,60
donc c'est tout simple he ils perdent
4,40 par par par unité donc voilà à ce
rythme là
euh d'abord vous avez eu les majors
américaines qui sont allés sur ce sur ce
business et qui on pouvait compenser par
par les les les choses plus
classiques que vous aviez je je suis
d'accord les Américains ont exploité un
filon et comme toujours ils l'ont
magnifié pour pour parce que c'est leur
style
euh mais dans 10 ans moi je vois pas ce
qui va se passer dans 3 4 ans mais dans
10 ans c'est un filon qui va être très
large
si si ça tient même disant enfin je veux
dire aujourd'hui on est à la deuxème
phase c'est-à-dire que vous avez des
majors qui ont payé des prix pas
possibles pour obtenir des terrains et
cetera comptant gagner de l'argent avec
ça qui se sont aperçus qu'ils en perdent
autant qu'ils voulaient et maintenant
qui essaie d'entretenir le myth pour
essayer de refiler ça à des au suiveurs
à de plus petites entreprises à des prix
pas trop vilains pour s'en sortir à peu
prss bon c'est le coup classique je veux
dire une fois que vous avez fait un
mauvais investissement vous essayez de
le refiler donc de pas trop dire que
c'est mauvais pour la petite
particularité qu' a eu là-dessus c'est
c'est pas que du style c'est pas les
majur qui ont qui sont allés chercher
c'est d'abord des compagnies qui se sont
créées pour faire ça qui ont pris les
droits ces compagnies se sont
introduites en Bourse en disant regardez
ça va être fantastique elles ont été
racheté à ce moment-là par les major il
y a 3 4 ans majors qui sont en train de
passer des dizaines de milliards de
moinsvalu sur les achats qu'ils ont fait
mais ça a servi à enrichir ceux qui ont
vendu la boîte en premier dans un jeu de
bon tau en effet vous avez maintenant
des droits qui en plus qui s'épuisent
parce que quand il quand il n'exploite
pas s' ne fort pas les puits ils perdent
les droits c'est très compliqué Philippe
j'aimerais que vous nous parliez des
produits dérivés sur ce marché financier
extraordinaire qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire sur les produits dérivés d'une
le volume de peut-être les possibles
menace que ça représente sur notre
économie surtout sur l'économie
américaine écoutez je vais
des dérivés de matières premières
puisqu'on évoquait le sujet alors tout
le monde a encore en tête de grandes
bulles spéculatives notamment celle de
2008 sur le pétrole
notamment imaginez également que les
dérivés de l'or ça représente un marché
énorme ou l'argent et cetera des marchés
des marchés dérivés sur l'or et l'argent
vous pouvez préciser oui ce sont des des
futurs des options des certificats des
certificats qui sont éventuellement
convertibles euh en métal physique faut
pas se faire d'illusion parce que le
plus souvent ceux qui vous disent que
c'est convertible ils n'ont pas les
stocks on l'a vu d'ailleurs récemment à
Hong Kong au début de l'été un
intermédiaire proposé effectivement la
possibilité de convertir et le jour où
les gens sont venus effectivement parce
qu'ils voulent pH global voilà euh non
non c'est à Hong Kong m MF Global c'est
une faillite là parce que ils ont
spéculé voilà de façon totalement
déraisonnable et
disproportionné donc la société de Hong
Kong dont le nom m'échappe euh elle a
carrément tout arrêté a décidé de de
stopper ses activités ne pouvant pas
livrer le physique et on était là je
vous dis sur des en cours de dérivé qui
sont euh tout à fait marginaux en regard
des dérivés un de devise et deux de
dettte alors aujourd'hui si l'on se fit
au chiffre de la bererie
euh on est entre 730000 et
750000 milliards dans cours sur les
dérivées de toute nature sachant il faut
que je m'assayille là sachant que
605 à 70 % des dérivés sont des dérivés
de dett sous toutes leurs formme alors
dett d'État euh det
hypothécaire
higheld alors higheld sous toute forme
dett d'entreprise dette de municipalité
ce qui a déjà été évoqué et cetera donc
grosso modo si vous voulez le l'encs de
des dérivés de dette de crédit crédit
automobile crédit tout ce que vous
voulez c'est 500000 milliards de dollars
bon le taux de progression est assez
facile à calculer puisqu'on était
redescendu à
445000 milliards de dérivés en mars
2009 donc 4 ans et 6 mois plus tard on
est à 730000 750000 milliards si l'on
euh continue exactement sur le même
rythme c'est facile euh on agrège les
injections de la Banque centrale
d'Angleterre du Japon des États-Unis ce
qui nous fait Bonom allant
150 milliards de dollars par mois
euh donc c'est facile hein ça fait 5
milliards par jour
tout cela investi à 70 % voire 80 % dans
des dérivés de devis et de de CR et de
dett au mois de juillet 2014 on aura
probablement atteint un en cours de 1
million de milliards de dérivé alors
actuellement qu'est-ce que ça représente
réellement pour les banques et tous ceux
qui investissent dans ces produit c'est
quelque chose de l'ordre de 30000
milliards B ça veut dire quand même
qu'on est est sur des leviers de 25 faut
réaliser ce que c'est que des leviers de
25 voilà c'est très très bien ce que ça
représente et bon par exemple pour des
banques françaises ou beaucoup de
banques d'affaires américaines leurs
encours sont sur des leviers de 40 voire
davantageem jusqu'à 60 en Allemagne pour
commerce ban donc voilà c'est ces
histoires sont sont proprement
vertigineuses
incompréhensibles pour un particulier et
je voulais juste avant de passer la
parole préciser que pourquoi est-on sur
ce genre de levier de 30 40 50 parce que
si on ne multiplie pas
ces achats virtuels de dett on n'est pas
capable de maintenir les taux au niveau
où ils sont c'est-à-dire
2,75 sur des typ Bones américains 170 à
75 sur
dubound 2 et5i pour en moyenne en Europe
ces Levi permettent de fausser par une
offre plétorique d'argent permett de
fausser le prix des des dettes le
véritable prix des dettes donc il y a à
la fois des leviers absolument
vertigineux et d'autre part un autre
phénomène qui est la spoliation bien sûr
des détenteurs de dett est-ce que vous
pouvez nous démocratiser un peu plus
cette information par rapport au volume
de produit dérivés est-ce que vous
pourrez ensuite enchaîner sur les taux
les menaces que ça représente la
position des différentes banques tous
ceux qui utilisent une banque savent
qu'il y a deux banques il y a la banque
qui a des liquidités fait des prêts et
puis il y a la banque qui prend des
engagements que dans le jargon bancaire
on appelle du hors bilan mais c'est des
engagements jusqu'à il y a 15 ans le
total bilan et h bilan ne devait pas
dépasser entre 8 et 12 fois les fonds
propre nous sommes arrivés à ce que
grâce au hors bilan ou à cause du hors
bilan les ratio fond propre total de la
banque se situe pour les banques les
mieux géré à 20 à 1 pour les banques les
plus risquées à 80 à1 80 à1 il y a un
établissement qui à la fin 2012 avait 76
lequel écoutez là là c'est pas une ceord
non non on va pas alors à partir de là
on peut se dire que ça doit diminuer
d'accord pourquoi est-ce que ça a
augmenté et pas à cause des banques
uniquement à cause des états elles ont
voulu placer vite et pas cher le papier
dont elles avaient besoin bon donc si ce
mécanisme banque état se modifie quel
est le risque pour le particulier le
premier risque pour le particulier est
que euh euh les les les banques en
prennent moins les les les états
maintiennent des besoins euh
d'endettement important et ben à ce
moment-là les taux montent alors si les
taux montent comme l'un d'entre nous l'a
dit à juste titre euh vous particulier
vous aurez vous serez stimulé à en
acheter mais vous particulier vous allez
à moitié pleurer hein c'est gens qui
rient gens qui pleurent parce que ce que
vous avez investi soit directement soit
dans des fonds de retraite va se
dévaloriser en effet si les taux montent
la valeur de ce que les banques ont en
obligation baisse c'est c'est c'est de
l'arithmétique financière de base alors
le risque pour nous tous hein c'est
que les taux montent la valeur des fonds
de pension et des fond de retraite
baisse les actifs dans lequels les fonds
dans lequels vous avez investi et moins
de valeur et que votre actif net
c'est-à-dire votre richesse personnelle
se voit diminuer est-ce que vous avez un
conseil pour se préserver de ce type de
mouvement écoutez moi je peux dire ce
que j'ai fait pour moi ça fait 8 ans que
je n'ai pas un titre pas une oblique et
que je suis en liquide
donc c'est c'est c'est une je suis
banquier c'est donc que je me méfie
considérablement de vos collègues pas de
mes collègues système c'est du système
du système du système d'accord Olivier
euh oui peut-être reondir sur deux trois
deux trois points peut-être pourra être
un peu plus concret sur les produits
dérivés euh faut peut-être expliquer que
les produits dérivés sont en gros euh
des instruments qui en théorie sont
censé re des instruments
d'assurance sur les différents éléments
qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure euh peut
être vu aussi comme des paris ça dépend
comment comment c'est fait mais euh
imaginons produit dérivé de de de de
change et bien on va faire un Paris sur
le cours du dollar dans un an et puis je
vais payer une petite prime et puis si
le dollar dépasse tel niveau et bien
dans ce cas-là on va me donner de
l'argent et puis si est inférieur
j'aurais perdu comme pour une assurance
donc c'est un système à la base et
intellectuellement qui est un système
très très relativement sain et qui
permet de s'assurer donc en théorie de
diminuer le risque parce qu' évidemment
si je suis exportateur euh européen mais
c'est un produit qui m'intéresse parce
que du coup je sais dans un an je
connaîtrai le prix ça ça revient quelque
part à connaître le prix du dollar dans
un an en tout cas de s'être assuré de
faire comme si on connaissait le prix du
dollars dans un an donc c'est très bien
mais le problème c'est que ça a été
complètement détourné de cette finalité
là et que ceux qui achètent les produits
ne sont plus des gens qui vont vendre
des produits aux États-Unis qui ont
besoin d'une assurance financière son
des gens qui font un Paris comme vous et
moi on dit juste tiens je donne de
l'argent et puis si si le dollar euh
monte et bien je récupère de l'argent
donc je fais ce ce Paris là en clair la
différence c'est que dans le premier cas
si je suis exportateur et que ça se
passe mal au niveau du dollar je vais
perdre de l'argent donc j'ai un risque
de perdre quelque chose ce produit
dérivé me permettait de m'assurer contre
cette perte quand on est passé en mode
Paris je ne risque plus rien quel que
soit le niveau du dollar en théorie qu'
soit haut qui soit bas ça ne me coûte
rien je prends juste ce ce Paris là ENF
comme je CIS Paris au cour c'est
exactement la même chose Olivier Philipp
excusez-moiivier Olivier Philipp est-ce
que vous pouvez rebondir sur ce que a
dit HERV et Olivier et est-ce que vous
pouvez me parler un petit peu du shadow
banking et ce que ça représente sur
l'économie US et sur l'économie
mondiale vous battez pas pour prendre la
parole al moi je vais rebondir sur ce
que vient de dire Olivier en ant une
précision c'est que beaucoup de ces
paris sur des produits obligataire sont
assez classiquement des arbitrages taux
fixe taux variable à terme alors 3 5 10
ans en fonction des maturités qui
existent sur le marché
euh mais euh on voit se reformer à peu
près le même genre de bulle euh qu'en
2005 2006 2007 sur les subprime on est
en train de les recréer purement et
simplement euh on recrée de toutes
pièces des euh dérivés euh de crédits
immobiliers ou de créances immobilières
alors pas seulement aux États-Unis on en
trouve maintenant à peu près partout on
recrée également des dérivés de crédit
auto enfin bon on a absolument pas
appris les les leçons de 2007 200008 on
est reparti de plus belle et on est
reparti en vous expliquant que
finalement peu importe la taille de
l'ancours 1 million de milliards fin
2014 mais de toute façon le système est
stable puisque tous ces Paris sont des
paris assurés il y en a don c'est le
métier de prendre du risque d'autres qui
se proposent de l'assurer et tout le
monde est d'accord pour que ça
fonctionne il y en a qui veulent du
risque il y en a qui veulent se couvrir
contre le risque donc on peut le faire
presque de façon infinie le problème
c'est qu'on l'a vu en 2008 les assureurs
ils n'ont absolument pas les moyens
lorsque les choses se passent mal de
remplir leurs obligations mais on
continue aujourd'hui de faire croire que
cette fois-ci ça va bien se passer et il
suffit vu la taille de l'encours qui est
une variation de seulement 0,3 % de la
masse globale à la baisse par exemple
pour provoquer des pertes gigantesques
et à 3 % de baisse de valeur de l'encour
Total la plupart des banques n'ont plus
rien au bilan leurs fonds propres sont
littéralement carbonisés et ce qu'on
sait en plus de ça c'est qu'avec la
puissance de l'outil informatique
lorsque les choses ont commencé à se
déballonner tout tout va aller
extrêmement
vite marche je dirais qu'on est dans une
situation qui est qui est qui est bien
pire que celle de 2008 parce que en plus
on se croit protégé c'est-à-dire que je
pense que les les banquiers ont
l'impression que on leur a mis des
règlements des contraintes qui font que
maintenant on a une bonne notion du du
du risque et qu'on ne risque plus rien
on voit ça sur ce qui est quand même un
peu effarant on voit aujourd'hui que le
le les les fonds propres et les ratios
sont
déterminés toujours avec le même le même
moyen c'est-à-dire quand vous avez un
pays souverain c'est pas c'est pas un
risque donc vous n'avez pas besoin de
mettre de fond propre en face quand vous
avez quelque chose qui est noté par nos
cherses agences de notation qui ont
quand même échoué lamentablement depuis
des
années en nous collant des sub prime
notés triple A et compagnie enfin bon
c'est c'est quand même ahurissant de pas
comprendre que ces gens-là ne servent à
rien par définition et baser un système
de risque là-dessus c'est complètement
fou or on continue joyeusement
c'est-à-dire que si vous avez standard
and pour ou mis qui vous
note quelque chose double A ou triple A
euh il y a plus beaucoup de triple A il
y a plus que Landouillette qui est à 5A
mais en dessous il y a plus grand-chose
mais vous en avez quand même aujourd'hui
des des des des triple A des double A et
c'est et celles-là sont considérées
comme indéboulonnable et ne méritant pas
que on mette un peu de fond propre en
face donc vous vous croyez protéger vous
pensez qu'il y a eu des règlements vous
pensez qu'il y a eu des choses qui ont
été mises en place depuis 2008 en fait
pas du tout tout donc on continue
exactement comme avant avec en plus une
masse qui a considérablement augmenté et
qui fait que maintenant le le les choses
sont tellement tendues que le moindre la
moindre petite poussière là-dedans peut
se terminer très très mal Philippe ouais
je voulais
juste apporter une petite réponse au
sujet du shadow banking donc ce shadow
banking bon c'est comme il est constitué
souvent des transactions de gré àé non
listé entre établissements et par et le
plus souvent d'ailleurs entre
établissements par exemple basés sur le
sol des États-Unis ou sol européen
est-ce un contrôle diplomatique un
contrôle des législateurs sur le shadow
banking est-ce que les les les les états
est-ce que nos ministres est-ce que
notre pouvoir est-ce que le pouvoir
américain a un regard effectif
opérationnel sur le Shadow B c'est à
tellement vaste sujet je pense qu'on on
va y revenir mais que je voulais juste
rester moi sur sur ce sujet précis du
shadow banking donc donc le principe
c'est effectivement conclure des
transactions de gré à gré entre un
établissement dans un pays où il y a une
surveillance et des pays offshore où il
n'en existe pas et pourquoi ce Shadow
Banky n'a pas du tout été
restreint ni encadré après 2008 bah tout
simplement parce que on a pris que des
demimesures on a créé une Volker rule
qui n'est pas appliquée de façon
elle est presque vidée de sa substance
aujourd'hui mais cette Volker rol a
amené les établissements
à créer des filiales de façon à ce que
aucune d'entre elles ne dépasse une c
une certaine taille critique qui
l'oblige à déclarer ce qu'elle fait donc
avant j'avais ma division banque
d'affaires qui faisait par exemple 50
milliards de chiffres d'affaires
maintenant j'ai 10 filial banque
d'affaires qui font chacune 5 milliards
et qui ne sont pas contrôlé donc le
shadow banking on le contourne et puis
on apprenait hier je vais cuer dans le
temps donc c'était le 17 ou 18 novembre
que la Fed décidait de reporter d'un an
la mise en application de la Volker rule
telle qu'elle existait t qu' était conçu
pour juillet 2014 ça sera repoussé à
2015 mais avec un intense lebying des
banques on peut s'attendre à ce que
cette Volker roule d'ici juillet 2015
soit totalement vid de sa substance
n'est plus aucune efficacité ni aucune
valeur contraignante HERV
Olivier
[Musique]
allez-y la réalité la réalité elle est
triple la première c'est qu'il y a
immensément beaucoup de capitaux et qui
ne font
qu'augmenter et que cette plor de
capitaux c'est très bien que ça n'est
pas en plaçant l'argent dans les banques
qui vont avoir le rendement minimum donc
ils font du chadow banking et ils font
du shadow
banking en dehors des règles bancaires
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont des équipes
d'hommes qui vont prêter à telle
entreprise prêter à tel particulier
investir sans contrôle des banque ça
c'est le le premier le deuxème c'est que
les banques ne sont plus en mesure de
contrôler pourquoi mais il faut lire le
livre de bernardke sur la crise de
193038 où il dit la principale raison de
la crise ça n'est pas
1929 c'est le fait qu'à partir de 32 les
banques ont mis à pied des milliers de
banquiers commerciaux capables de faire
des prêts et que quand nous avons voulu
redémarrer ces banquiers comme le Fils
comme le père du directeur général de la
ch quand j'étais jeune était devenu
chauffeur de taxi donc il ne faisait
plus de la banque depuis 15 ans bon le
troisième point c'est que la réalité du
risque est camouflée à tous les niveaux
hein les banques ont des pertes en
interne très importantes qu'elles ne
montrent pas les banque centrale n'exige
pas la transparence les organismes
chargés de faire les audits en dis
encore moins et les directions générales
se tèisent dans toutes les langues donc
si nous prenons les remarques qui
viennent d'être faites et ce contexte
bien caractéristique de pas
d'information une volonté farouche des
dirigeants de continuer à à gagner des
fortunes un manque de contrôle et une
hypocrisie générale nous voyons que nous
sommes dans dans un milieu risqué avec
des acteurs
qui feront des choses contraires à
l'intérêt général Olivier c'est
difficile de rebondir après ça quand
même le diagnostique tout à fait tout à
fait justeci et tout à fait tout à fait
lucide donc en effet c'est scandaleux
c'est qu'on a rien fait de sérieux après
2008 où en septembre 2008 je pense que
tous les banquiers de la planète sué à à
grosse boutte dire tout le monde a
compris que on était quand même pas très
loin d'un écroulement généralisé on a
rien fait de sérieux c'est c'est
vraiment du
replatrage et encore dans certaines
mesures arriveront dans 5 ou 10 ans euh
et que on a rien fait et c'est pire
qu'avant je vais vous citer un un petit
un petit chiffre sur les monnaies les
marché d'échang sur la
planète justement tangibiliser un peu
les les choses il y a tous les jours 70
milliards d'exportations sur la planète
hein il se vend donc il s'échange 70
milliards donc on peut dire que si on
voulait s'assurer surtout bah ça
coûterait il faudrait 70 milliards
d'assuranceces et encore je tiens même
pas compte du fait que ça se fait
souvent dans la même monnaie en euros ou
ou en dollars mais VO alure de grandeur
ce serait peut-être au maximum 70
milliards tous les jours sur la planète
en 2007 il s'est changé 3000 milliards
de dollars donc évidemment la plupart
c'était juste des gens qui pariaient sur
le yen hein Philippe ont pari sur le yen
demain ça monte ça baisse tiens je te
donne de l'argent on voit ce qui se
passe c'était 3000 milliards par jour en
2007 en 2010 c'est passé à 4000
milliards par jour on vient d'avoir le
chiffre en 2013 5200 milliards par jour
donc évidemment les exportations ont pas
beaucoup changer sur sur sur donc on
voit que on a un système qui en effet
regorge de regorge d'argent on SAV plus
quoi en faire et donc on fait des paris
on fait des paris tant que tout se passe
bien comme disait Philippe aussi
effectivement on faire des produit
dérivés on peut faire plein ça gonfle ça
gonfle ça gonfle oui c'est toujours
quelqu'un de solide en face il y a pas
de problème il suffit qu' en ait un qui
qui tombe pour que tout pour que tout s
oule on n pas fait grand chose en 2008
la seule réaction du G20 ça a été de
faire une liste de banques
systémiqu le G20 a fait une liste en
disant on avz première liste 29 je crois
ou 30 c'est les 30 banques sur la
planète on les a identifié il y a les
noms pour le coup si une banque tombe il
y a un cataclysme planétaire ça risque
d'entraîner toutes les autres banques
avec elle et donc toutes les économies
qui sont effectivement lié aux banques
après face à ça qu'est-ce qu'on fait bon
on va peut-être mettre un peu plus de
capital on va voir mais le fait de se
dire comment on accepter l'existence de
structure l'existence d'une banque
systémique comment on peut accepter ça
intellectuellement alors qu' suff de
couper la banque en ou 4 à la rigur sans
même aller chercher des trucs très
méchants dire on va diminuer la taillein
le risque vol
roule oui
ENF so plus costud
roule Morgan ou Goldman sa pense que
c'est pas c'est quand même vraiment pas
le bonheur de grandeur en tout cas
l'idée elle est là en France on avait 5
banques systémiques on est
quasiment pas champ les ÉtatsUnis
d'abord on en a autant que l'Angleterre
il en avait CIN bon il a plus que quatre
rassurez-vous Dexia vient de sortir de
la liste pour les raisons que vous
connaissez bon on va peut-être arriver
en effet à zéro il en a qu'une en
Allemagne qui déjà pose beaucoup
d'inquiétude aux Allemands pourquoi on
en a quatre fois plus que les Allemands
pourquoi là on nous dit pas tiens pour
le coup l'Allemagne là c'est peut-être
un modèle à suivre avoir qu'une seule
banque systémique on voit qu'on ne pose
pas ces questionsl HE c'est surtout
comment ne pas remettre en cause le
système alors qu'on sait il y a pas
besoin d'être trotquiste que c'est
dangereux c'est formidablement dangereux
pourquoi on n'est pas capable d'exiger
le même degré de sécurité financière
qu'on exige de sécurité nucléaire che
alors que les risques sont quand même du
même ordre de grandeur sur la perception
des risques on a pu voir avec les
fluites d'Edward Snowden que l'État
américain essayer d'anticiper les
risques à tout prix quitte à s'asseoir
sur la constitution et sur les paires
fondateurs et à s'asseoir surtout sur
ses alliés je voudrais avoir votre
réaction RV sur la
le comportement prédateur au niveau de
l'acquisition des renseignements que ce
soit sur le milieu bancaire que ce soit
sur le milieu économique qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez d'un point de vue
personnel et d'un point de vue un peu
plus
professionnel
écoutez
commençons par une constatation qui est
que la capacité à connaître tous les
mouvement financier et le résultat d'une
succession de révolution technologique
et qu'on ne va pas revenir dessus hein
et que
euh nous pouvons dire c'est immoral
que cela soit ainsi j'ai été chif
exécutif dans une banque anglaise qui a
créé le mécanisme de contrôle de tous
les flux financiers entrant et en
sortant de l'Europe
et nous avons été obligés par les
banques centrales européennes à donner
notre fichier quotidien aux Américains
donc c'est la r quelle année il y a 15
ans il y a 15 ans nous nous remettions
tous les soirs à
Washington
le le à Washington à la sec ou à
Washington ou pouvoir exécutif je ne le
sais pas d'cord je peux pas inventer ce
que je ne sais pas je ne le sais pas ce
que je sais c'est que l'ensemble de ces
mouvements financiers touchant l'Europe
pour le reste du monde était partagé
avec les Américains et que l'argument
qui nous avait été donné c'est qu'il
fallait saisir l'argent salle l'argent
de la de de de la père et cetera
bon je ne vois pas cette situation
changeant est-ce que je trouve qu'elle
est moralement condamnable le c'est une
limite évidente
à une
emprise triste sur notre vie privé mais
elle est hein et nous en venons à un
deuxième point qui est
elle est parce que le rapport de force
entre les États-Unis et l'Europe ne se
renforce pas énormément au profit de
l'Europe Philippe au niveau des
comportements prédictifs sur les flux
financiers qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire la la hyper frequency trading
est-il bqué par des algorithmes de la
NSA est-ce que la NSA est devenue la
pointe de diamant des comportement
prédictif pour le système financier
américain je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
chercheurs les plus performants les plus
innovant al certainement il en avoir un
certain nombre qui travaille pour la NSA
je pense que Goldman sax et JP Morgan
ont également une pépinière de de
chercheurs
très très innovant très pointu en ce qui
concerne l'espionnage on semble avoir
complètement oublié il y a une dizaine
d'années qui existait
échelon qui nous espionnait depuis la
pointe de la cour no enfin qui
espionnait toutes les conversations
téléphoniques mail euh maintenant bon on
voit que prisme est simplement un peu
plus performant hein avec la loi de mour
j'imagine qu'il ont un taux de
couverture bien bien supérieur
aujourd'hui
euh en fait il y a depuis fort longtemps
et à un certain niveau euh un
comportement collaboratif entre les
grandes oreilles américaines les grandes
oreilles françaises les grandes oreilles
israéliennes alors évidemment il y a pas
de
collaboration évidente entre avec les
Russes ou avec les Chinois qui eux par
contre sont peut-être dans un système
d'échangement enfin bon tout le monde
espionne absolument tout le monde al on
trouve ça immoral ou pas
immoral c'est comme ça au li de la
marche qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire làdus moi je rebondirai simplement
sur ce que Monsieur de carmois a
dit ça fait ça fait 15 ans que ça dure
probablement même beaucoup plus que 15
ans et on a l'air de découvrir ça
aujourd'hui comme d'habitude c'estàdire
que les Français poussent des cris d'or
frais en disant mais c'est pas possible
les Américains nous
espionnent-ils oui nous espion
il nous espionne depuis ça fait depuis
la guerre que ça ça ça vous en
particul ça représente pour
vous enfin personnellement n'ayant pas
grandchose à cacher je m'en fiche
complètement mais ça c'est juste pas
très agréable de penser que on peut
écouter vos conversations et que on peut
voilà alors maintenant on peut aussi
s'amuser et à chaque fois qu'on décroche
en téléphone dire terroriste bon et
compagnie parce que ça marche sur des
algorithmes et que donc vous serez
écouté et leur balancer après un certain
nombre de bêtises mais je veux dire
c'est c'est c'est très désagréable point
bon maintenant moi j'ai pas j'ai pas de
secret d'état et et donc personnellement
s'ils m'écoutent ils vont pas apprendre
grand-chose qu'il ne sachent déjà
donc Olivier berer je voudrais votre
avis sur l'accord transatlantique sur ce
pointl moi j'aimerais j'aimerais quand
même rebondir je c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est assez terrifiant
quand on quand on regarde en quelques
années évidment le principe est vieux
burette qui qui espionnent deci de là
mais ce qui a vraiment changé c'est
c'est c'est les capacités c'est qu'ils
ont maintenant largement les capacité
d'enregistrer 100 % de toutes les
communications téléphoniques qui sont
passées dans le pays et d'archiver ça
tranquillement évidemment la NSA est en
pointe sur ce sur ce sujet là les
réactions d'ailleurs européennes et
françaises ont été très intér à ce
niveau-l on a bien vu qu'assz rapidement
il y a des protestations pure forme
parce que évidemment le gouvernement
français fait un peu la même chose sans
doute en beaucoup moins bien à son grand
regret parce qu'il a pas encore les
capacités on sa très bien qu'il a aussi
ce genre de ce genre de pratiques qui
sont faites qui sont faites en France
alors on peut dire en effet bon
finalement c'est vrai des secrs c'est
désagréable je te confirme aujourd'hui
c'est aujourd'hui c'est mon souci c'est
pas c'est évidemment immoral mais bon à
la rigur on peut dire morale o on en est
dans notre société aujourd'hui mais
c'est dangereux c'est dangereux
j'aimerais finir sur ce pointlà c'est
dangereux qu'est-ce qui se passe si
comme c'est quand même aussi un peu le
sens en ce moment on rentre dans des
régimes de moins en moins démocratiques
euh ça aurait donné quoi ça en
1940 le facebook de Jean Moulin je pense
que c'était intéressant à avoir pour pas
mal de personnes et c'est vrai qu'on est
un stade aussi où on fait quoi on voit
que c'est pas on va l'interdire c'est
c'est vraiment possible et et si on
prend un peu de recul c'est assez triste
puisquon se rend compte que
systématiquement euh l'espèce humaine
vous lui donnez un peu de confiture il
mettront la main dedans alors évidemment
ce sera au début pour lutter contre
évidemment le terrorisme et les barbares
mais enfin bon on enregistre quand même
100 % des communications on sait jamais
euh euh et vous avez ça sur plein de
sujets vous avez ça évidemment alors là
sur l'informatique vous avez ça sur la
biologie en ce moment des chercheurs
sont en train de bricoler le virus de la
variole parce que des fois on sait
jamais euh vous donnez l'énergie
nucléaire rapidement on fait des bombes
nucléaires euh pour le moment ça s'est
encore pas trop trop mal passé sauf pour
le Japon ça aura donné quoi au bout de
300 400 ans on sera plus là pour le voir
mais enfin on peut aussi être inquiet
sur cette incapacité à dire essayons
d'être un peu prudent et d'être un peu
raisonnable moi je dirais même que la
NSA c'est l'arbre qui qui masque la
forêt quelque part puisque les agences
de renseignement américaines qui nous
espionnent sont au nombre de
14 elles ont toutes leur leur
spécificités prè ça porte malheur qu'
fasse quelque chose donc et parmi ces
agences qui nous espionnent alors
certaines sont effectivement là dans
l'intelligence économique donc ell essa
de savoir qui essaie de passer des
contrat avec qui il y en a qui
espionnent purement les brevets il y en
a qui espionnent les transactions
financières il y en a qui est enfin qui
essayent de de collecter du
renseignement sur toute la finance
opaque mais enfin souvenez-vous ce
chiffre 14 agence de renseignement la
NSA n'est que la plus grosse mais
chacune effectivement a son son champ
euh
d'investigation avec de de de deux
petits scandales juste pour finir deux
coups de gueule un contre l'Angleterre
qui me semble-t-il fait partie de
l'Union européenne et qui la porte
d'entrée des États-Unis pour espionner
tous les câbles transatlantique qui
passe chez elle comment on accepte qu'un
pays de l'Union européenne espionne les
autres pays et non pas pour le
terrorisme mais vraiment pour
l'espionnage économique principalement
c'est prvisé qu'on qu'on exporte des
informations pas fraîches ou avarié oui
ça doit être ça doit être ça donc bravo
é européenne à deuxième point Edward
Snowden qui tout de même grâce à lui on
a appris plein de choses et povga est à
Moscou on lui refuse l'asile politique
pour pas déplaire aux États-Unis et on a
été quand même à deux doigts d'abattre
le l'avion du président c'était quoi
bolivien je crois il me semble bien euh
parce que peut-être peut-être qu'il
était qu'il était dedans en c'est quand
même une folie furieuse et on fait tout
pour justement décourager les lanceurs
d'alertes et le Japon vient de présenter
une loi pour punir les lanceurs d'alerte
et donc protéger il y a quand même
quelque chose qui est euh je trouve
inquiétant c'est c'est la dérive
totalitaire dans tous les pays
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui on est dans
dans une situation où on voit quand même
que les États sont acculés sont dos au
mur pourquoi parce qu'ils ont un montant
de dette dont ils savent pas quoi
comment faire pour le pour le le
l'annuler ou le réduire ou s'en sortir
ils n'ont plus de croissance devant eux
et aujour aujourd'hui ils son dos au mur
et quand c'est exactement comme quand
vous blessez une une bête à la chasse ça
devient très
dangereux et et et là on est aujourd'hui
avec un dénis de démocratie européen
mais ça ça fait quelques années déjà et
et on est dans une dans un état qui a
une une dérive qui n'est plus respecté
parce qu'il n'est plus
respectable et qui est en train de
dériver dangereusement donc c'est vrai
que maintenant avec les moyens qu'ils
ont euh ça risque d'être un peu
compliqué pour nous avec des choses
assez inimaginables enfin quand on voit
que le Guardian hein qui a recueilli les
toutes les données de de Snowden a été
obligé en Angleterre de détruire les
disques durs où la police est venue au
Guardian pour vérifier qu'avec un
marteau il détruisit bien les disques
durs où il y avait les informations de
Snowden en plus avent dit il aà copi à
l'étranger hein mais ils ont dû quand
même réflch de secondes l'Angleterre qui
en plus le pays de la vas corpus qui a
demandé à un journal de détruire les
disques dures d'information qui est sur
les États-Unis j'ai j'auris une question
pour HERV euh vous avez été
vice-président de la Commission
Trilatérale vous revenez de kracovi si
mes souvenirs sont bons vous avez
participé à la Commission Trilatérale
récemment euh sans trahir le secret des
dieux qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire sur la perception qu'à la
Trilatérale sur ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis sur l'économie américaine
quelles sont ces préconisations et
allez-y je vous en prie la
préconisation je dirais de presque tous
les pays
Trilatérale d'Europe et d'Asie c'est
plus d'Europe hein plus d'Europe
c'est-à-dire une Europe plus musclée
plus plus structurée dans le domaine
financier qui arrive à prendre des des
mesures qui assureront la croissance
européenne à long terme et et et et
que beaucoup de pays européens beaucoup
de pays asiatiques trouvent que notre
transformation vers l'unification et
vers
l'action de la
Communauté européenne et de est très
ralenti bon la deuxième c'est qu'il ne
pense pas que ça va
s'accélérer il considère que avec une
Angleterre très réticente et l'ambigué
américaine qui rappelons-le est quand
même à
l'origine l'Amérique est à l'origine du
mouvement européen Jean Menet à
travailler 25 ans aux États-Unis donc
c'est bien le rappeler c'est bien le
rappeler non mais il faut ils sont à
l'origine mais quand il voit l'Europe se
développer comme l'un des grands moteurs
des Américains c'est le pouvoir si pe
possible
prééminent ils
ont des comportements où ils veulent
bien que l'Europe se fasse mais à un
rythme qui leur permet de préserver leur
prééminence monsieur Béchade monsieur de
la marche et Monsieur beruer qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire sur ce censé
veiller sur nos problèmes ce censé
conseiller nos dirigeens quelle opinion
vous avez des S tank à l'heure actuelle
si vous avez un sank nous recommandé ou
si vous avez un sank qui a fait des PR
qui sont retrouvés
complètement dans le vent ou dans les
choux
euh sur les S tank j'ai pas de j'ai pas
de j'ai j'ai rien à à dire sur les sur
les S tank j'aurais à dire
surank là déjà sur les sur les quelques
sur les quelques conseillers de de des
gouvernements successifs qui me
paraissent
très très déficient on va dire pour pas
dire autre chose euh déicient par
rapport à leur perception ou par Rapp
par rapport à tout enfin on a on a quand
même des des des gens qui traînent dans
les cercles du pouvoir et qui ont échoué
à chaque fois qu'ils ont été dans une
société je ne citerai pas son nom enfin
il est et et qui nous délivre ses
pensées qui n'intéresse personne sauf
lui
peut-être depuis depuis des années et
des années donc enfin je veux dire et et
aujourd'hui quand on voit quand on voit
les actions qui sont menées
par notre gouvernement on peut pas dire
quand même que on suiv un
chemin très intelligent donc voilà ber
on peut dire à moi sur l'Europe c'est
intéressant ce débat malheureusement moi
j'ai tendance à penser que toutes les
dérives néolibérales depuis les années
80 ont tué le projet européen parce que
le projet européen est devenu maintenant
synonyme de
d'hyperfancierisation de de troïca de
tension majeur
entre entre les peuples et euh et ça a
été fait pour l'échec de l'euro en cours
il mettra sans doute le le le le dernier
clou et c'est dommage d'avoir transformé
une idée à la base plutôt intéressante
de coopération raisonnable et
constructive entre entre pays européens
euh en un
projet certes poussé à la base par par
par les États-Unis mais sans doute une
vision très faussée onont-il essayer
d'appliquer leur propre modèle modèle
européen qui n'a quand même pas grand
chose à voir de se dire on va faire les
États-Unis d'Europe on est tous pareil
un Allemand un espagnol un Français
quelle différence culturelle aucune donc
on peut unifier tout ça et faire un seul
pays et puis puisquon est on fait une
seule monnaie avec des stratégies en
plus où certains acteurs ont vraiment
témoigné clairement en disant dans les
années 80 on voyait que l'Europe
n'avançait plus FL alors on va pas faire
comment on fait pour les ÉtatsUnis
d'Europe bah tiens on fait une monnaie
unique parce qu'on sait très bien que ça
va poser des problèmes au bout de 10 15
ans et là les gens n'auront plus le
choix hop ils seront bien obligés
d'aller faire d'aller faire no nos
États-Unis d'Europe euh sans voir
qu'ement ça peut aussi foirer
lamentablement ce qui est quand même le
la direction à laquelle vers laquelle on
se on se dirige enfin avec une
inconséquence que je trouve assez
criminel parce que finalement il se
passe quoi au final c'est une résurgence
du nationalisme hein évidemment si sur
un sujet aussi sensible avec les dérives
qu'il y a eu dans le passé sur les
nations vous arrivez à essayer
d'agglomérer le tout euh contraire au
volonté volonté populaire tout à l'heure
ça avance pas beaucoup l'Europe dernier
sondage est-ce que vous voulez plus
d'Europe oui 19 % c'est bien réparti
d'ailleurs gauche- droite c'est sûr
c'est pas c'est pas une meilleure façon
de de de faire progresser de faire
progresser le sujet donc la question
comment on va réussir à détricoter les
erreurs qui ont été faites sans tout
jeter sans jeter le bébé avec le dubain
comment on fait pour que justement on
garde quand même le point principal qui
a un minimum de coopération et d'entente
en Europe
on voit très bien qu'on a des
gouvernants qui sont pas prêts du tout
de faire machine arrière de revenir à
une Europe puissance une Europe qui a
des vraies politiques une Europe qui
fait de l'erbus et non pas une Europe
qui aujourd'hui interdit de faire Airbus
par que aujourd'hui essayer de faire une
entreprise publique concurrente une
entreprise américaine et puis on en
reparle c'est évidemment tout à fait
interdit aller faire un Eurosoft pour
concurrencer Microsoft pour qu'on ait un
outil pour gérer nos ordinateurs qui
soient Open Source histoire de savoir si
par exemple le le président américain a
pas un bouton pour éteindre tous les
Windows de la planète ça s'appelle le
kill switch ouis ça c'est quand même des
sujets des questions et bien on en parle
pas et en plus quand même on en
parlerait c'est interdit dans dans dans
les traités européens on a mis dans les
traités européens gravés dans le marbre
la liberté de circulation des capitaux
ce qui est une hérésie c'est forcément
quelque chose qui poussera infin à ne
plus pouvoir gérer un pays puisque vous
aurez de toute façon la menace des
marchés des marchés financiers liberté
de circulation des capitaux qui
s'investissent oui très bien mais les
capitaux spéculatifs dont on parle
depuis un moment qui peuvent rentrer le
matin être reparti une heure après en
ayant déstabilisé est tout à fait
inacceptable et qu'est-ce qu'on a marqué
dans les traités non seulement il y a ça
en plus il faut l'unanimité pour venir
en arrière c'est marqué dans le traité
de Lisbonne il faut l'unanimité pour
venir en arrière sur la liberté de
circulation des capitaux la liberté des
gens non ça il y a pas de souci pe se
faire la liberté des capitaux c'est noir
sur blanc regardez il y a un joli
article là-dessus monsieur de carmois je
je voudrais avoir votre opinion
sur l'intégrité du pouvoir élu
législatif face aux banques est-ce que
vous pensez que nos états sont
suffisamment équipés pour pouvoir
résister et imposer leur volonté pour
l'intérêt général face à un lobby
bancaire
exent qui court en fuite en cavalerie
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
les mesures à prendre pour renforcer
l'état son intégrité par rapport aux
décisions prises sur cette terre qui est
très
compliquée il faut voir est-ce qu'il y a
un langage commun c'est-à-dire un
objectif commun et si si on prend comme
hypothèse que l'objectif commun aux
États-Unis en Europe de tous les
gouvernements de droite ou de gauche
c'est la croissance économique hein si
on prend ça comme hypothèse alors on est
obligé de se demander
si les banques jouent leur rôle les
états jouent leur rôle alors pour que
les banques puissent jouer leur rôle il
faut qu'elles aient à la fois des
capitaux et des hommes pour pouvoir
investir avec les PME les entreprises
qui se développent les particuliers
entrepreneurs à l'heure
actuelle les banques ne le font pas
pourquoi ne le font-elles pas parce
qu'elles ont absorber des montants
colossaux de dett d'État pas simplement
d'État en bonne forme comme l'Allemagne
mais desétats qui ont des difficultés et
que
les états contrôlent totalement le bilan
des banques et ça nous n rendons pas
compte ce qui pourra arriver de mieux
aux banques c'est que les États leur
disent écoutez on vous rachète et on
finance ailleurs tous
vos toutes vos dettes d'État et on vous
impose de refaire de la banque c'est
c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce que c'est de la
banque on vous demande et c'est la
deuxième mesure que je recommanderai que
vos fonds propres par rapport à tous vos
engagements bilanciel ou horors
bilanciel ne dépassent pas 12 à un ce
qui va impliquer messieurs qu'il va
falloir que vous réduisiez vos effectifs
et ça va impliquer que vous réorientiez
vos hommes vous recrutiez de nouvelles
équipes pour faire du crédit à
l'économie chose que l'État ne sait pas
vraiment faire j'en veux qu'un exemple
la difficulté qu'elle a à décoller de la
banque publique
d'investissement monsieur béchad
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
les capacités à mettre ce type de mesure
en place face au montant de l'argent je
dirais fictif ou dérivé est-ce que vous
pensez que les États sont capables de
mettre ça en en en place estce que c'est
c'est réaliste face à la montagne que
nous avons accumulé pendant ces années
je pense que tout le monde autour de
cette table a bien compris que depuis
2008 toute tentative de régulation de
réglementation sont systématiquement
torpillé aussi bien au Congrès
américain qu'à Bruxelles torpillé par
qui et bien par ceux qui effectivement
veulent continuer d'agir de se comporter
comme avant la crise qui veulent
continuer de gagner beaucoup d'argent
très vite sur des produits qui n'ont
aucune utilité économique réelle et le
métier de banquier c'est quelque chose
qui est
tellement c'est c'est presque
soporifique on investit sur du très long
terme avec des perspectives de retour
sur investissement parfois assez
incertain
c'est du détail c'est tout ça c'est très
très laborieux alors que si un petit
génie a trouvé une nouvelle martingale
un nouvel algorithme qui permet en
quelques heures de capter un gros
écart sur sur un dérivé de dette
quelconque et bien est évident que la
priorité va à ce genre d'opération on
parlait tout à l'heure de des S tank
aujourd'hui on va dire que l'utopie
réalisée et bien c'est celle de du
libéralisme inspiré de l'école
autrichienne sauf que on
a refondu tout ça dans une sauce
d'ultralibéralisme et de défaut total de
contrôle donc on a complètement
dévoyé la pensée de l'école autrichienne
montpèlerin tout ça a été ensuite repris
et reconfiguré par l'école de Chicago
porté jusqu'à Washington par la Banque
centrale américaine par donc tous les
réseaux d'influence dépendant de l'école
de de Chicago et on est arrivé donc
instaurer un système dans lequel il y a
quelques opérateurs qui baignent comme
des poissons dans l'eau de très grandes
banquees d'affaires et notamment Goldman
sax l'élite de l'élite de la pensée et
de la compétence financière euh qui
fournit un secrétaire d'État
pratiquement sur deux aux États-Unis qui
fournit des banquiers centraux donc à la
BCE Marc carnet en Angleterre
vice-président de la Banque centrale
d'Australie tous les membres de la fête
soit ont à un moment un autre fait un
passé une partie de leur carrière euh
soit dans une grande banque d'affaires
soit ont travaillé à ou dans des
universités ù l'école de pensée est
celle que l'on connaît et celle qui
impose la pensée unique donc aujourd'hui
pour sortir de ça pour que les États
reprennent la main et comme disait
monsieur garnois effectivement que les
États reprennent leur dett aux banques
et reprennent en fait quelque part le
contrôle le la liberté parce que les
banquiers les créanciers tiennent
évidemment ce tienent tiennent les
emprunteurs et je pense que dans tout
cela il y a pas de hasard quand il y a
autant d'argent en jeu c'est jamais du
hasard
donc je pense que les banqu ou en tout
cas certaines pensent qu'elles ont
peut-être une mission divine elles
accomplissent peut-être l'œuvre de
Dieu a fous qui peuvent penser ça enfin
qui qui non quand même penser ça elles
accomplissent elles accomplissent
l'œuvre de Dieu
en G je vous coupe sur l'œuvre de Dieu
euh j'ai une question qui pour passer du
coqu à l'an je je voudrais vous poser
une question qui a l'air peut-être
surréaliste à vos yeux c'est est-ce que
vous pensez que les
comportement hors du commun que certains
traders ou que certaines salles des
marchés ont pu avoir est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire si vous êtes favorable
à un contrôle des
stupéfiants dans les salles de marché
pour éviter que l'on ait des directeurs
de fond des directeur de de de salle de
marché qui prennent trop de risque par
rapport je vais vous dire c'est c'est
notoriété publique il a beaucoup de
cocaïne qui qui qui tournent dans les
salles de marché est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à ce que on teste comme un
pilote d'avion les traders les
directeurs de banque sur les stupéfiants
testons tout le monde parce que
quelquefois quand on entend les discours
de Monsieur Bernand que on peut se
demander s'il a pas fumé la moquette
avant
donc pourquoi pas mais s'il avait la
fumé la moquette il aurait pas cette
position
vous avez beaucoup de gens sur lesquels
on peut se poser beaucoup de questions
donc s'il fallait tous les contrôler on
passerait notre temps à ça
euh vous pouvez aussi contrôler le
président de la République son ministre
de l'Économie parce que quelquefois ils
ont des discours qui sont plus que
curieux
donc on peut se demander s'ils ont pris
des substances illicites ou non monsieur
beruer sur
sur ser fav oui bien sûr mais c'est ce
que je vous ai dit moi j'ai vraiment une
une conviction forte qui est d'appliquer
à l'industrie financière les mêmes
normes que l'industrie nucléaire et en
particulier vu ce qui se passe et vu les
risques qui sont pris par les opérateurs
de marché ça me semblerait une très
bonne une très bonne initiative moi
j'aimerais faire une petite remarque ça
fait maintenant 2 heur qu'on parle du
diagnostic de de de la crise des
analyses qui sont quand même pas très
très très
différentes ce qui est pas très étonnant
parce qu'en plus moi j'ai tendance à
considérer qu'il faut pas pas peine être
très intelligent pour comprendre ce qui
se passe faut juste un petit peu
d'honneté intellectuel et de regarder un
peu dans le détail de pas se laisser
endormir par les par les sirènes moi
j'étais assez frappé du des propos d'vé
parce qu'ils sont je pense que c'est la
première fois qu'on voit un banquier de
cette taille qui les tient en français
on n pas l'habitude d'entendre ça en
France dans le monde anglosaxon beaucoup
l'ont dit les anciens PDG de City group
tous ceux qui ont uvré la démolition du
classagle les anciens pr Morgan Stan
vous fait une liste comme ça une
vingtaine de de personnes de la carure
d'Hervé qui en parleà en France pourquoi
onentend jamais un ancien banquier tenir
des propos assez assez assez dur c'est
déjà une vraie question moi j'aimerais
demander à à à RV parce que bon on pose
de diagnostic c'est bien on va peut-être
parler tout à l'heure d'idée de solution
ma question c'est pourquoi ça ne se met
pas en place moi c'est ça que j'aimerais
avoir votre vision pourquoi après je
répète cette vision où tous les
banquiers en 2008 ont eu des grosses
gouttes en se disant tout va s'écrouler
on arrive à un système on n'est pas
capable de prendre de prendre des
mesures qui en plus sont pas
spectaculaires c'est des points ça nous
ramène en gros 1980 hein moi quand je
suis né et quand j'ai eu 10 ans il y
avait toujours qu'un fixing par jour à
la Bourse de Paris et il me semble que
le pays se portait pas trop trop mal il
même de ou tris points de croissance en
plus à l'époque hein aujourd'hui ça
paraît inimaginable de dire après tout
une action ça a une valeur pendant une
journée c'est la même c'est une norme
comptable d'ailleurs pas sû ce soit pas
détourné on pourrait imaginer des trucs
comme ça c'est pas une révolution
imaginez qu'on va donner un dividende
triple à des actionnaires DEP plus de 10
ans pourquoi pas ce genre d'idée simple
on n'arrive pas à mettre en place des
choses de bon sens qui en plus ont déjà
été mis en place par le passé d'où vient
le problème qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
pour que ça change sinon on pourra
parler ça va s'écrouler une deuxième
fois et on pourra là encore se réunir en
disant on avait raison les amis bon
malheureusement on a comme à Chipre une
ruine de de tous les épargnants oh ben
il y a une réponse de bon
sens pour passer de nous avons on peut
dire en gros le même système bancaire la
même organisation dans les banques avec
des
nuance d'informatique à droite et à
gauche en 2013 quand 2000 quand 1980
hein on n'a pas changé pourquoi n'a-t-on
pas changé l'organisation des banques en
interne au cours des 30 dernières années
alors que vous prenez renult hein pour
prendre quelque chose de bien français
auou peugo ils se sont complète
transformé sur les marchés sur les
méthodes de travail sur leur marketing
et cetera parce que nous ne recrutons
pas au sommet des banques des hommes qui
peuvent conduire le changement nous ne
les recruons pas nous recrutons des
types remarquablement intelligents nous
recrutons des gens qui ont fait
l'Inspection des finances ou le corps
des mines mais qui n'ont pas toute cette
formation qui commence en bas en bas il
faut commencer en bas pour comprendre
comment un employé de banque travaille
pour comprendre comment le petit client
réagit et qui montant dans sa hiérarchie
sait comment conduire le changement
premier point et pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
ne veulent pas l' prendre hein ils ne
veulent pas la prendre pour deux raisons
c'est que la
l'essentiel 30 à 40 % de du bénéfice des
banques provient des activités de marché
et que pour arriver à retrouver une
vraie rentabilité en diminuant les
activités de marché il va
falloir réorganiser en profondeur la
banque de haut jusqu'en bas et pour ça
il
faut apprendre et mettre en œuvre la
conduite du champ j'ai j'ai j'ai une
question par rapport à cette
réorganisation Hervé à l'heure actuelle
est-ce que vous pensez pas
sincèrement que nous avons dépassé le
point de non retour pour une refonte de
de cette organisation bancire je je vais
dire prenons cas de fukjima nous avons
un premier réacteur qui a flambé oui
et les mesures que nous allons
uniquement pouvoir faire c'est des
mesures
palliatives sur un système bancaire à
l'échelle mondial globalisé est-ce que
vous pensez pas que cette refonte
tellement importante et tellement
profonde que le courage nous manque et
que le courage manque à nos décideurs
politiques mais il est jamais trop tard
hein si si on on
écoutait les gens de 55 60 ans
1947 dire mais on va jamais avoir une
industrie française moi j'ai entendu ça
toute mon enfance mais non mais non car
moi il y aura pas d'industrie française
on ne sait pas faire une industrie
française bon très bien il y a eu des
gens menés il y a eu des grands
industriels les ples de l'ouvriers et
compagnie qui ont fait ça donc
aujourd'hui il faut des hommes qui
affirment qui qui soit compétent et qui
soi prêt à à à à transformer les les les
les banques et l'expérience que j'ai eu
à Londres où j'ai pris une banque qui
avait 18 niveaux hiérarchiques
18 niveaux hiérarchiques hein c'est
colossal qui n'avait pas changé pendant
100 ans hein sauf que son effectif avait
doublé et ben on l'a fait il faut
l'expliciter on a expliqué ce qui'est
aux petits Anglais hein qui qui qui que
on avait été la première banque il y a
100 ans on était la 28e aujourd'hui on
se donnait 5 ans
pourevenir la 10e et on l'a fait donc
tout ça c'est un problème de leadership
c'est pas un problème intrinsèque à la
banque monsieur de la marche je crois
que
déjà on a on a déjà loupé une fenêtre
d'opportunité qui était 2008 quand vous
voulez négocier avec quelqu'un il vaut
mieux être en position de force là
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on a fait vous
aviez des banques qui avaient des
grosses sué comme disait
Olivier à ce moment-là il fallait leur
il fallait pas leur donner le choix
fallait leur dire bah écoutez voilà
c'est comme ça que ça va se passer et
puis et puis pas autrement vous signez
en bas de la page nous on va se charger
de remplir les gouvernements l'ont pas
fait les gouvernements ils ont sorti les
banques de l'eau ils les ont séché ils
les ont réengressé et et à ce moment-là
ils les ont convoqué à Bercy et ailleurs
en leur disant excusez-moi nous de vous
déranger est-ce que vous pourriez euh
faire un geste et euh euh faire ce qu'on
vous demande
qu'est-ce qu'ont répondu les banques à
ce moment-là ils ont simplement fait
peur aux dirigeants en disant attention
si tu nous embêtes on prête plus
d'accord donc comme tout le système
repose sur de l'argent gratuit sur des
taux à zéro ce qui est la plus immense
bêtise qu'on puisse faire puisque ça ça
fait une mauvaise allocation d'actifs
systématique et donc ça se termine
toujours de la même façon c'està-dire
très
mal et que tout le système repose sur de
la dette et de l'émission dette
perpétuelle donc vous avez un dirigeant
qui se retrouve à face à un banquier qui
lui dit si tu m'embêes je prête plus il
paniqué il dit excusez-moi de vous avoir
dérangé vous pouvez revenir vous pouvez
repartir dans vos bureaux donc tant que
ça durera et tant qu'on naura pas
quelqu'un comme disait monsieur tapis
sévèrement burné qui pourra dire au au
banquier non c'est comme ça et c'est pas
autrement et ben vous aurez toujours le
même le même problème
personne n'a voulu enfin on a bien vu
Olivier était très en pointe là-dessus
sur le sur la la réforme
bancaire quand on a dit à Monsieur
oua que il fallait
peut-être diminuer son bilan il a dire
mais moi mais les activités de marché ça
représente 3 % de mon activité comme ça
en regardant ou 2 % en regardant droit
dans les yeux le député qui a dit ah bon
je croyais que c'était plus excusez-moi
de vous avoir dérangé monsieur
de vous avoir posé la question
donc quand vous avez quelqu'un qui ment
comme un arracheur de dents face à un
député qui lui pose une question
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire et que
vous avez le député qui en plus de
l'autre côté s'écrase en disant ah bah
excusez-moi j'avais mal compris bon bah
vous pouvez être sûr que les choses
n'avanceront pas maintenant il faut
vraiment une décision politique et il
faut vraiment quelqu'un qui a envie de
la mettre en œuvre et pour l'instant à
part les déclarations de Monsieur
Hollande qui disait que son premier
ennemi était la finance ça n'est resté
qu' oui je pense qu'ils sont devenus
amis
et ça resté simplement une déclaration
éid vous éti au BFM Award hier soir
est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire
remonter une petite information que
vousvez livré en off sur les
déclarations de Monsieur trich c'était
très amusant alors évidemment beaucoup
de gens vous diront enfin Monsieur
tricher toute façon il est à la retraite
et ce qu'il a dit n'a absolument aucun
intérêt mais c'était quand même assez
assez amusant il a dit il a dit trois
choses il a dit que à son son avis
personnel
euh il souhaitait que on revienne à un
système de taux de change
fixe qui était de la part d' l'ancien
patron de la BCE quand même quelque
chose d'assez intéressant la deuxième
chose qu'il a dit
c'est que certains devraient se poser
tout de même la question tous ceux qui
voient la reprise et la fin de la crise
pouvaient se poser des questions puisque
quand toutes les banques centrales du
monde utilisaient des des mesures non
conventionnelles et à un rythme effrainé
on pouvait quand même se poser la
question de savoir si on était
réellement sorti de la crise ça c'était
pour ceux qui voyaient la crise derrière
eux je suppose petit message et et le la
troisième chose qu'il a dit intéressante
c'est que il a dit
euh pour tous ceux qui critiquaient
aujourd'hui la BCE en disant qu'elle ne
ne rentrait pas dans le jeu de la BoJ de
la Banque du Japon et de la Fed
c'est-à-dire à faire tourner la planche
à habiller et à faire des qe successifs
il disait je vous rappelle tout même que
depuis déjà un certain temps c'est open
bar illimité ce sont ces termes open bar
illimité à la banque centrale européenne
pour les banques qui peuvent venir se
financer en échange de n'importe quelle
cochonnerie d'ailleurs puisqu'on abaisse
régulièrement les niveaux de qualité des
collatéraux et que donc maintenant la
BCE
est ressemble plus à une poubelle qu'à
une banque centrale monsieur Béchade
oui euh les chiffres parlent de même le
bilan de la BCE est supérieur à celui de
la Fed bon heureusement grâce à Janet
yen il y a peut-être une chance que les
États-Unis repassent devant mais bon
mais monsieur dragou Dr monsieur drag
est là en
embusc pour pour peu qu'il a un feu vert
de la Cour constitutionnelle de Carl
schou pour effectivement des ltos
liimités pouvant se transformer
effectivement en quantitativeing bon on
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge évidemment
en ce qui concerne l'impossibilité de
réformer le système ben je pense que
c'est assez clair on a ce qu'on appelle
la consanguinité et la collusion
consanguinité entre les banquiers et les
très hauts conseillers que l'on trouve
alors pas seulement à Bery puisque là
effectivement entre l'Inspection des
finances Polytechnique et cetera on
retrouve à peu près les mêmes aux
États-Unis qui hantent les couloirs de
la Maison Blanche chaque secrétaire des
d'État au Trésor américains est flanqué
d'au moins trois ou quatre conseillers
issus
tantôt de Goldman sax tantôt de City
group voilà et il y a ce qu'on appppelle
le système des revolving Doors
c'est-à-dire que on fait quelques années
de carrière dans une banque évidemment à
la haute direction pas dans les étages
inférieurs et puis on intégre l'équipe
dirigeante alors peu importe qu'elle
soit républicaine ou démocrate ou en
France de droite ou ou de gauche les
gouvernements passent les banques
restent donc on a cetteéologie
bientôt très
pass donc donc là on a cette
consanguinité et ensuite aux États-Unis
on a quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus
assumé qui est la collusion c'est-à-dire
que depuis un arrêt de la Cour suprême
qui autorise maintenant une entreprise à
financer de façon tout à fait ouverte un
candidat n'importe quoi un Chérif à
l'échelon local un maire un député un
gouverneur un sénateur c'est tout à fait
transparent et c'est d'ailleurs é c'est
d'ailleurs été l'excuse c'était de dire
jusqu'à présent on avait des des
systèmes de financement opaque on va
moraliser tout ça et maintenant et ben
on saura que tel candidat une élection
porte la la casquette k fried chickens
ou la casquette Hally Burton ou la
casquette
bah supportée par quelques banques
influantes de Wall Street donc quand on
a à la fois consanguinité et collusion
on ne peut pas réformer le système c'est
pas le tout d'avoir une utopie où on dit
qu'on va pouvoir changer les Ch les
choses ou créer une institution comme la
Trilatérale où on se dit que on ne on ne
reverra jamais une 3e guerre mondiale et
on contiendra l'expansion du communisme
et cetera l'échelon planétaire il faut
effectivement une utopie et il faut des
gens pour la porter mais quand tous les
gens qui sont au pouvoir sont issus de
la même école de pensée montpellerlerin
Chicago euh qui sont tous passés par les
mêmes ils ont fait tous les mêmes
parcours euh banque banque d'affaires et
ensuite on va dire les ors de la
République ou les salés du pouvoir et
bien quand on est là je vois
effectivement difficilement comment on
peut réformer donc deux derniers mots on
va terminer par Olivier beruet et
ensuite Hervé vous prendrez la parole
pour clore ce débat Olivier le problème
démocratique est en effet un enjeu
majeur dans ce qui dans ce qui se passe
on peut l'illustrer avec l'histoire de
la séparation des activités
bancairesement je j'ai vu ça d'assez
près c'est amusant cette idée de
simplement dire bon on va demander aux
banques de de se scinder en deux de
faire si elles veulent la même chose
mais chacune de leur côté une qui va
prêter à l'économie réelle avec un vrai
mission de service public et l'autre qui
va être une banque pas qui se chargera
de faire les produits assuranciels ou
les produits dérivés dont on parlait en
tout cas on faire en sorte qu'elle se
contamine pas l'une l'autre cette vision
de séparation c'est ce qu'il y a eu en
France entre 45 et en pratique 1995 ça a
été la règle dans notre économie c'est
depuis 95 en pratique on a changé ça
donc on a mis les risques ensemble et en
10ant ça fait faillite donc c'est quand
même un super modèle euh quand on dit il
faut séparer qui dit ça aujourd'hui vous
avez à peu près tous les prix Nobel
d'économie hein de sttiglitz Maurice
alle le disait felps le dit qui était
l'élève de Friedman donc de gauche de
droite Nicolas bavrez dit qu'il faut
séparer donc en gros toute
l'intelligence économique mondiale dit
il faut le faire moi j'ai pas trouvé un
prix Nobel qui dit qu'est-ce que c'est
malin de tout mélanger il n pas vous
avez plein d'anciens patrons de banque
en dans le monde anglo-saxon qui le
disent de banque universelles dis donc
on a vu on a essayé mais c'est c'est
trop dangereux faut laisser tomber vous
avez en France vous faites un sondage
sur les cadres des banques la moitié des
cadres vous disent déjà faut séparer
vous avez le Financial Times qui vous
dit nous la régulation on n'aime pas
trop ça mais là commme faut pas déconner
sinon ça va s'écrouler on a un mode
comme ça qui dit voilà y a pas une voix
à part les banquier en poste aujourd'hui
qui qui disent qu'il faut laisser le
modèle actuel et au final on voit qu'on
a on ne le fait pas on ne fait pas en
Angleterre on ne fait pas aux États-Unis
on fait pas en France on fait pas en
Espagne on fait pas en Italie quand même
une vraie question pourquoi en tout cas
euh ça monte la puissance de ces réseaux
de ces modes de penser qui euh qui voilà
qui empêch toute toute réforme et et
après il s'agit pas de faire des
discours sur mon ennemi c'est la finance
il s'agit de dire c'est pas un ennemi la
finance c'est des gens qui font chacun
leur boulot du mieux qu'ils peuvent
malheureusement il y a plus de règles
générales il y a plus de vision
d'intérêt général et donc quand chacun
suit son petit intérêt particulier ça
fait pas du tout un bien-être collectif
ça fait une faillite une faillite à long
terme he le mot de la fin
mot de la fin c'est que nous parlons
d'argent et que l'argent c'est comme la
langue des HES c'est la source de tous
les biens et de tous les mots bon si on
prend la France on peut dire que dans
l'ensemble nous avons bien géré nos
systèmes bancaires nous les avons mieux
géré que le reste de l'Europe
certainement mieux géré que les
États-Unis et infiniment mieux géré que
le Japon donc acte que nous avons dans
l'ensemble eu une Banque de France et
des banquiers qui ont été prudents reste
que doivent-ils faire pour continuer à
contribuer à la croissance et de la
France et de l'Europe diminuer la
finance diminuer la finance et
réorienter les ressources internes en
homme et en capitaux vers
l'industrialisation le commerce
international l'investissement et je
pense en France que
il y a un une prise de conscience depuis
5 ans chez les banquiers que c'est ça
leur mission principale ce qui fait que
je suis assez optimiste sur l'avenir de
l'activité bancaire française et de
l'activité bancaire européenne très bien
sociét je suis désolé je voulais pas
rebondir dessus mais en tout cas moi
j'ai pas du tout la même vision sur le
fait que nos banquiers se sont bien
comportés il y a qu'à regarder Société
Générale à faerkererviel ils ont fait
SATER une fois en 2008 contrepartie AIG
ils ont failli sauter une deuxième fois
en 2008 Dexia a fait faillite le Crédit
Agricole a perdu un bras en allance
demande pourquoi en Grèce on a 100000
milliards de produits dérivés en France
dans nos quatre banques systémiques
voilà donc tout cas j'ai un désaccord
ici sur ce sur ce point là au niveau de
la gestion du système bancaire relatif
hein on n'est pas bon ou mauvais on est
meilleur que les autres préciser d' si
vous voulez d'accord euh
je vous souhaite une excellente journée
et j'espère à bientôt et merci
[Musique]
encore des types comme Kusa il y en a
pas il y en a pas beaucoup cette espèce
d'aplon incroyable avec lequel les les
yeux dans les yeux de tout le monde il a
dit je ne mens pas vous pouvez me croire
et cetera il y avait un truc comment
peut-on imaginer que un politicien va
être en mesure de se dire non non
attendez l'intérêt général c'est la
défense des libertés fondamental liberté
fondament c'est la défense de la vie
privée et là il y a un
conflit c'est impossible en France le
problème c'est que le
motur diabolisé on oublie simplement que
ce sont des gens qui privilégient les
résultats sur les méthodes et qui sont
capables de gagner une connaissance
intime d'un système